quite a bit of time after breaking his
thumb actually here in that game on the
29th mo bamba
nicely done by charlie brown junior to
go straight up bomba though there for
the tip-in and if you're bomba you're
relieved because the last two times he
backed you down and things went joel's
way you give him the jumper gladly
will shoot that three and makes it
[Music]
anthony behind the back to bomba looking
for his second three of the first
quarter and he's got it
able to come over after the initial
pumpkin fur khan lost the defender
bomba for three
well these magic are shooting pretty
darn well from beyond the arc
10 overall
got a nice little arc on it with a soft
touch it drops
so be three for five from the floor
bomba this cube oh he is shooting the
lights out tonight
but i like the idea from joel
brown jr trying to slow down anthony
behind the back bob look in her first
fourth three in the first half and he
drills it
that's interesting that amy pointed that
out because it has been the battle of
big man but bomba's been doing all of
his work from outside five of six from
downtown now from obama
wide open looks sixers just didn't go to
him
just four shots tonight it's good
recovery by drummond there
and another
but the third time the charm for bubba
in the magic dribble to get into a
rhythm and then pulls up
four 22 for bomba make it 25 and he's
got a new career high from distance in
the first half six of seven this is what
we're talking about the longer you keep
a team in it
like the magic now the more emboldened
they are
bomba with the block
three on two for the magic
quick off the floor good llama 9 of 12
from the floor suggs pokes it away from
maxie drummond there to clean it up the
rest of the team 8 for 31. so moe has
made more field goals and has another
block there
wagner what a transition before this
quarter
really before these last couple of
minutes he didn't have any blocks three
the rest of the team eight for 31 so moe
has made more field goals and has
another block there
wagner what a transition
25 points for mo four rebounds three
blocks two assists
looking for more
make it seven seven of eight from three
from obama